Here are five fun facts about the Cherry Blossom Festival in Washington, D.C.
Number 5: In 1912, Tokyo, Japan gave 3,000 trees to the United States...
...as a gesture of friendship.
Approximately 150 trees still remain from that first donation.
Number 4: Roughly 1.5 million people come to Washington, D.C. each year...
...to watch them bloom and to take part in the associated activities.
Number 3: The gorgeous cherry trees grow in 3 major park areas,...
...near the title base in West Potomac Park and in East Potomac Park.
Number 2: The trees continually require watering, pruning,...
...disease and insect control, fertilization and wound treatment.
These tasks are carried out by the tree crew for National Capital Park - Central.
Number 1: In 1910, the very first shipment of cherry trees...
...arrived in Washington, D.C. from Japan.
Two thousand of those trees had to be destroyed due to disease...
...as they were infested with roundworms and other insects.